JEANNOT IS CHECKED.
CALEB JONES COMINGAND
HERE COME THE PREDATORS.
NOVAK  THE THE LEAD.
THOMAS NOVAK IS ONLY PLAYING IN
HIS 27THHIS LEFT HIP WEEK AGO W.
WITH THE SHORTHANDED SITUATION
THE AVALANCHE ATTO CONNOR ITTOOA
CRAZIARY OUT7 TIMES.
THE ABILITY TO STAY UP BASED ON
ICE HERE.
THAT ENDS UP TURNING DEFENSIVE .
HE CLEARS IT THEIKE THAT LEFT  A
BIG SAVE BY FLEURYSSED OPPORTUNY
THERE.
HE WAS ALL BY HIMSELF, PASS WENF
PHILIPP KURASHEV.
SO GOOD TO SEE JAKE MCCABE
REAL 5 RED.  IT ALIVE.
EKHOLM -- I SHOULDVER GOT
THROUGH.
AS THIS ONE GOES
OUT OF TO FORSBERG.
FORSBERG LOOKS TO  THE BACK
OF THE NET.
AND THE REACTION FROM FORSBERG
IN BEHIND.
HE WAS GOOD.
TOEWS WINS THE DRAW
THE PREDATORS TRYING TO CATCH Y
HIM, IT'S AN